these are howler monkeys their habitat
spans from southern Mexico to northern
Argentina looking at them you may find
it hard to believe that such small
animals can make a sound that's like a
combination air-raid siren and heavy
metal guitar solo
the fact is howler monkeys are
considered to be among the loudest
animals on earth well you be the judge
hell where monkeys have what's called a
hyoid bone in their throats that serves
as a kind of amplifier plus their semi
saggy throat pouches further amplify
their orations why do they howl like
this only the male's how they probably
do it to let other howlers know where
they are they're very territorial
so the howl is as much keep away as it
is Here I am
Howler's live in the canopies of trees
feasting on leaves flowers buds and
fruits
they have long prehensile tails that are
used as a kind of fifth hand to help
them identify things they can weigh up
to about 15 pounds and sleep up to 15
hours a day which is good news for their
jungle neighbors I mean you wouldn't
want this going on 24/7 and it drive you
crazy